and with reaction former congressman Fox
News contributor a guy who never lost
the case as a prosecutor you know Trey I
actually thought of doing it for the
whole hour because I have that many
questions about I'm trying to give a
flavor you got five minutes you better
get yes or no questions in and lay out
the facts for the broader audience in my
opinion yeah and you need to have
started two weeks ago and you need have
an objective you need to have a purpose
five minutes goes by quickly you're not
going to be able to cover all those five
tranches you and I talked about last
time I was on your show but just keep in
mind Mahler found some things you can go
there he didn't find some things you can
go there he didn't bother to look for
certain things you can go there and then
you have the the issue of the bias
within the investigation and then you
have another category legal issues it's
interesting to me whether or not you can
even obstruct an unprejudiced agait ssin
you can certainly resist unlawful arrest
so if the investigation was
unpredicatable begun so those are five
tranches but you got to be prepared and
I'm sure both sides will be for tomorrow
let me ask you if you have five minutes
is it better to ask the shorter
questions to get the facts out because I
believe there's an entire audience that
doesn't know Hillary paid for Russian
lies that were used to spy on an
American citizen commit fraud against
the FISA Court but this was predicated
on an unverified material that people
like James Comey swore was verified how
does he not investigate that but he had
time for taxi medallions and farrow
violations former congressman trey Gowdy
well he's not going to help you much
he's going to look he doesn't want to be
there he made that very clear in his
press conference he doesn't even want to
testify he's not going to deviate from
the report for two reasons quite frankly
number one prosecutors are not supposed
to deviate from their charging decision
or non charging but here's the real
reason let's assume he does say
something new or different tomorrow your
follow-up question is going to be why
the hell was that not in your report
anything new or different or special
your interesting day says tomorrow if he
had time for fara and loan applications
how does he avoid a Russian dossier full
of lies
were used to spy on a presidential
candidate in 2016 how do you avoid that
issue he does need to be asked about
what he did not look into I think the
answer is gonna be he's gonna blame rod
Rosita he's gonna say look you can call
the guy that hired me and the guy that
set my jurisdiction
but I would spend almost all of my time
asking him about things he did not
bother to look for such as the origin of
this investigation in June of 2016
that's where I want to know why he
didn't why he didn't delve into a phony
Russian dossier that was spread to the
American electorate on the eve of an
election and used to spy Russian lies
used to spy bought and paid for by
Hillary on the opposition party
candidate that is unconscionable
considering his mandate took them in
every other direction trey Gowdy good to
see you thank you